-Everyone's probably asking you
the same questions
about "Game of Thrones"
and it's the final season.
but I was gonna ask you,
do you have a top five maybe
iconic moments
of your character,
of Arya's moments on the show?
-I do.
I mean, there are so many.
But in terms of things
that have really defined her,
I think number one would be
Ned's beheading in season 1.
That was what
spiraled her whole arc.
-Yes.
-And then she was with the Hound
for a long time.
I think there was a line in
maybe season three
where she was like, "One day,
I'm gonna stick a knife
through your eye
and out the back of your skull."
That was, like,
a pretty defining moment
when you realized how --
[ Laughter ]
how messed up in the head
that she'd become.
-Yeah.
-And in season five,
I think she threw away
her original costume.
And I was in that costume for
like four years or something.
So, she threw that
into the water,
and it was
a really emotional moment.
I guess last season,
she reunited with Sansa again,
so that was a pretty big moment.
And then they both united
and killed Littlefinger,
and that's pretty --
-That's like kind of -- yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's not bad.
This is the final --
the final season.
Everyone's been waiting.
Can you tell me anything?
Are you allowed
to talk about anything?
-I've decided to just keep
a tight lip on everything.
HBO have sent out a lot of memos
recently about just say nothing.
-Yeah.
-So there's really nothing
that I can say.
They would absolutely kill me.
-You couldn't give --
You couldn't give
one little spoiler,
one little hint of a
a little --
a crumb is all I ask.
[ Laughter ]
Milady. Just a crumb
is all I'm asking for.
[ Laughter ]
-Um...I don't know.
Like, during shooting,
the final days
were really, like, emotional,
saying goodbye
to all of the cast.
Because when I found out that
Arya died in the second episode,
I was --
[ Audience gasps, laughs ]
-What?
Are you kidding me?
That's a spoiler.
[ Laughter ]
-Is this live?
-No.
-We can edit that out.
-Are you serious?
-Yeah.
-Dude, yeah, totally.
-They're still
gonna tweet about it.
-No. Don't worry about it.
Are you serious?
It's fine.
-I'm really sorry.
-No, don't worry about it.
No, it's fine.
-Okay.
-We can edit it, right?
Yeah.
We can edit it out.
Don't worry about it.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
Don't worry about it.
No one's gonna --
It's fine.
It's cool.
Let's just start --
Can we do applause,
and I'll just go
from the applause
and go into it again?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's talk about, uh...
Let's talk about the final --
Let's talk about
the final season.
-I'm...
-Um...
Is she okay?
We'll just go...
-April Fools!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-You were so good!
Oh, my gosh!
We got you guys so bad!
Maisie Williams, everybody!